merci beaucoup d'abord au merci madame
le pen pour le les échanges que nous
avons eus parce que il faut être deux
pour pouvoir mener ces échanges jusqu'au
bout et je combats vos idées je combats
le le parti qui est le vôtre et son
histoire et son positionnement politique
mais je vous respecte en tant que
personne mais je respecte je veux
convaincre toutes celles et ceux qui ont
pu vous suivre on a parlé beaucoup de
sujets évidemment il ya aussi des sujets
vitaux pour nos compatriotes nous
n'avons pas pu évoquer c'est la règle du
jeu de sujet du handicap qu'on a
simplement esquissé mais me tient à
coeur immensément de l'égalité femmes
hommes dont nous avons trop peu parlé de
nos territoires ultramarins nous avons
aussi trop peu parlé voilà donc il ya
une liste par prétérition que je
pourrais faire mais je crois au fond qu
on a pu voir une chose c'est que nous
avions des désaccords sincère
respectable et que cette élection est
aussi un référendum pour ou contre
l'union européenne et le lien qu'il ya
entre la france et l'allemagne à
référendum pour ou contre une ambition
écologique parce que nous partageons pas
du tout les choses en la matière un
référendum pour ou contre la laïcité la
fraternité en république quand on vous a
entendu défendre ce que vous avez
défendu sur le voile est donc un
référendum pour ou contre ce que nous
sommes profondément d'où nous venons ce
que nous avons à faire
donc je crois que le 24 avril c'est un
moment clair il faut que le choix soit
clair les 40 dernières secondes qui me
reste je veux les consacrer à nos
enfants on a parlé de notre jeunesse qui
a tant souffert pendant le coc vide et
au fond on se bat tous chacun avec nos
différences nos sincérité pour nos
enfants et moi c'est une des choses qui
m'importe le plus si les françaises et
les français me font confiance c'est de
continuer à leur bâtir un monde meilleur
à travers toutes les politiques que j'ai
défendue mais aussi de mieux les
protéger la protection de l'enfant sera
au coeur des cinq années qui viennent
leur solitude parfois leurs doutes leurs
difficultés à vivre dans ce monde de
plus en plus incertain je crois doit
être au coeur de nos combats politiques
ce sera en tout cas au coeur du mien est
de mon engagement
[Musique]